scheiße
das war eine falle ach so ich war
schnell die sportplätze 23 viel weizen
habe ich hier gefunden
strings und naja kommt kann ich alles
raus also in kisten ist nicht sinnvoll
ist dann nichts sehe ich gerade an bord
mit dem ich habe es ja ich hab kein
place place place place auch genau halt
mal oder tötet ihn ein bisschen mit ball
ganz mit der spitze gegen die spanne
abtransport keine neuen mehr sofort die
spanner und dann ja erst mal solltet ihr
enthüllt werden
um ist alles voller sports unglaublich
was wir jetzt brauchen auch immer wieder
neue schicht auf erstmal weg gemacht ich
bin jeden moment weder christus redstone
drin ja dann musik besitzt wird
ich komme gleich vorbei ich komplett
vorbei stunden goldene apfel ja redstone
kannst du mir geben das brauche ich
dringend
danach kann ich mir dann meinen generate
auf jeden fall schon mal bauen entschied
nämlich schon von da ab denn der lernst
wollen die mich der falschen ich weiß es
nicht ob sie das wollen
das mag jetzt mal die kapo ich komme
einfach nicht geschnitten
du hast hier reingeworfen hast du gesagt
unten die genau als das cinema ohren
dann können sich kurz mit kurz hinter
und begrüße ich das wäre doch ein ballon
irgendwie sehe ich gerade jetzt macht es
mir bitte die blades kaputt war damals
komplett dazu ich habe noch mehr als
eine vage geholt wait for me 81 sind die
places auch sind die putze ich gehe mal
kurz in arroganter angeber was ich jetzt
so ich kann mit dem zauberstab der
erreicht japan blöcke du scheiße ich
brenne
der reichte paar blöcke kann ich einfach
hingehen
ja ich weiss musste mich verzählt ja
noch hell vom leben ich habe mich ja ich
habe ich ein gläschen wasser als karl
der zauberstab halle 13 bereich weil ich
gern kann die autos 13 black entfernung
abbauen man muss gar nicht daran
hey kürbisse
so ich habe mich kurz auf dann gehe ich
wieder runter muss man wissen
strategisch machen ja nicht so viel
action und so die strategie wenn sie ins
wasser etwas gebremst egal ich heute
sagt ich mache meinen kaffee die ersten
richtigen es auch bei der ersten fahrt
wahrscheinlich ja also einfach weiter
aufnehmen muss ja klar du kannst
schneiden bank fürs zuschauen wir
sehen's nächsten folge und lösungen
dafür die waadtländer bei die letzte
bisschen länger ich hab mich jetzt an
die parts von lucanet und schärft das
selbe neben sandwiches ok 321 jetzt so
halloren alle zur nächsten folge die
zweite frage ist wieder mit kokain schon
die dritte kannst ja doch ganz einfach
drauflos ausweichen und dann hier
trotzdem reichlich eventuell mal deine
helfen helfe den helfenden hände wenn
sie das ist jetzt mal einen spot on
turkey ich bin dabei ich 1 202 sind weg
walter dann gibts auch noch lange sehe
ich gerade ist das wäre gar nicht
aufgefallen achtung keine zu schaden
gekommen wie so viel schaden ich hab'
ich habe kein eisen hosen kommen noch
rüstig aber jeff beck hält man es kaum
rüstung passiert ziemlich viel merke ich
gerade wenn du stehst könnte theoretisch
seine sachen behalten doch einfach töten
erlaubt wäre
da kannst du nicht doch du kannst du
mich dort nicht wird natürlich kriegen
würde ja aber ich werde es versuchen
mich zu schlagen sofort wegfliegen muss
ein lern und zack bin ich weg
dann will ich oben schießt mit
sauerstoff dich runter da bist du dass
irgendwas geklopft was richtig leider
sei aber dass places wahrscheinlich
etwas anderes
okay ich gehe ich weiß das hört euch
hier nochmal das ist echte sonne hin und
her zeitreihen laufe kassier wieder
weglaufen
ich hätte meine hose anlassen sollen ich
glaube die ganze drumherum von perversen
nach minimum scheiben hat minimum
schärfer da wahrscheinlich getränke jobs
an rote line geht los wo bist du samstag
hier bin ich wenn die kisten drin
nein war nicht und man keine kissen
weber nicht doch aber da geht's runter
da geht es runter er meine ich ja da
gibt es darunter waren so komische
löcher überall wo es hakt das wieder so
übel welt geht nicht voll komisch das
unglaublich wie das skelett nicht trifft
wenn du einmal außer sie noch nicht
zaubern dann dann fast mich halt
verzaubert nein ich brenne ich scheiße
drei herzen
ich werde jetzt mal was die places
luftgekühlt keine hauptpflicht werden
vielleicht betten mitnehmen sollen dabei
gut gewesen virtuell
aber verschafft töten ich habe alle
getötet hier erfassten place the stone
age
das gibt's ja gar nicht wo kommen die
alle her
scheiße das war eine falle
ach so ja gut dass da ja muss aufpassen
spor noch bin ich runter gefallen womit
einmal runter gehen ich bin ja ich komme
gleich mal zu dir also ich hab mir mal
das kurzen ruhe gelassen weil ich
problems ich hab mich ich habe hätten
eisen hause mit dem sollen ich hab nicht
gedacht dass heftig wird
ich versuche da gab's ein bisschen
runter zu gehen
strategisch ist einfach grossartig
nötigen utensilien
ich kann auch wieder einfach hoch
fliegen
so ich werde mich jetzt von hinter van
kesteren buddeln höhe welche ganz leicht
bestehen und wird versuchen ist man die
esports klippen oder zu setzen
das ist gar nichts wertvolles drittel
hätten uns borner erst auf den 200
erstens vorne gehen gut habe ich das
kann ich auch das skelett gegnerin geht
ich habe eisen gefunden
ja ich habe auch also von alten schlager
das erst mal sache die ich nicht brauche
hat tools astrein gesagt ja aber da sind
ja keine werte richtig wertvollen sachen
drin egal ich muss ja auch irgendwie
raus kommen haben jetzt einen weg
gebracht
bob von 1
huber nein ich gar nicht ich muss mich
ein bisschen organisieren das ist
unglaublich
ich gehe ich jede fraktion hat man hier
bleib hier platz steht das team
verstehen
dafür fordert den anderen da da bist du
über die händler die atrium genau das
was diese scheinen prinzessin durchaus
diese biene doch mal zwei schritte
zurück da warte ich hab gerade viele
sachen lauf genommen
ich brauche was ich zwei schritte zurück
laufen ja wie sabine keine ahnung
samstag zwei kurven die bräunlich schade
ist ein brunnen ada warendorf grunde
dürfte und nix drin sein glaube ich ja
was in den brunnen anderen grund mehr zu
drin
wir sehen wie sehen die aus da ist nix
drin die siehst du dann ein zweites mal
jede menge ruinen noch richtig komisch
wohin denn es noch mal was wollten so
viele ringe war noch keiner von anderen
sind erstens sind wie gesagt das denn da
würde ich gerne rund aber den ganzen
places aber leider nicht die richtige
richtung an
hier waren zwei skeletten und der
sonnenküste waren 2020 ist in der kiste
nichts drin also hier waren doch welche
auf die alte abgebaut ist so ich kann
man nach oben fliegen und gucken ob ich
oben region ist auch noch skelett bonner
auf einmal kommt ein krieg direkt vor
mit global access dreistellig direkt
vorm ich kann dinge aus einer oberen
christian fast 32 preisen einmal toll
dass wir nach rechts gehen ich sehe noch
was will youtube allerdings sehe ich
auch noch was vor was gibt sich alles
dinge wo bist du denn nach rechts ist
wie geht das mache ich mir über direkt
über die guck mal da ich mich auf das
was sind stücken ihre stimme trüben
gehen dass mit dem zoll auch unter
einfach ist besitzt doch meinen namen ja
bauen oder so blöd da ran gehen wir vor
bester position er ist in so ein
komisches baumhaus das war richtig
komisch damit man screenshot von gerade
kann aber es ist irgendwie so baumhaus
teil den ganzen das kreml im eingang
kaviar da kommt
darunter ist auch im falle irgendwie
glaub ja ich kann den aber zu machen
hier
dazu bauen denn ich ganz einfach das
verbrennt gleich einfach ab was der
ganze baum der cella waren drin
ich kann das den grabmalen löschen auch
das aber riesig ja ich hab das ich hab
das zeigt gerade gelöscht der schon
krass groß denn ich habe meine sachen
die ich brauchte also von mir aus ich
glaub ich geh wieder zurück ich habe die
kiste gefunden mit apfel und schrott
halt wieder zu explosionen
ok also hier war hier war und eine kiste
versteckt war wieder so ein fall ist
wahrscheinlich wenn die auslastung alles
zusammen stürzte ein stützen
was war da drin
ein apfel und nachholen so ist ich habe
zugelassen dass ich brauche noch drin 70
auswahl aus pharma ist nicht mein base
trotz so der jäger rucksack ist vor was
man da ist noch drin
36 weil ich für die ganzen chickens bei
mir hatte ich aktiv mit rucksack wie
macht man sich noch viel wie heißt er
auf englisch becken text einfach
rucksack dass es auf deutsch wenn es auf
deutsch englisch englisch wird dann gäb
haltbar backpack ein dass diese
komischen bunten ja da steht sie wenn
sie den rucksack aussieht dann ist es
ein rucksack so und wie welchen solchen
nehmen wenn ich dann da einfach alle
möglichen anteilen packen möchte ging an
den mit allen möglichen geht nicht da
brauchst du die bienenzucht ziemlich
weiter bis das hinkriegt ich habe auch
nur die hierfür bergarbeiter rucksack
ich habe den schmuck sein ich hab den
jägerhof sagt ich habe fünf vier
rucksäcke bei mir grande inter
ja da kommt doch mein körper von der
seite während ich im inventar bin
deshalb bin ich schön auf dem baum immer
ja gut dann war das erst mal nicht viel
ich bin da ich bin dafür dass wir gerade
mal vielleicht seien die andere richtung
gehen
da kommt so ein abenteurer rucksack
welchen rucksäcke hast du nur in berka
weiter rucksack in jäger rucksack im
rucksack